joining us now with reaction former
Deputy Assistant the president Fox News
contributor Sebastian Borka former
Arkansas governor Fox News contributed
Mike Huckabee here will be the headline
dr. korkor
Hannity says media is like drug addicts
and you know what I do because they wake
up every day and they gotta hate this
president and they have ignored so much
what do you think's going on Sean Happy
New Year that was quite the monologue
I'm gonna go one step further in the
commercial breaks between the CNN
segments I think they're handing around
a crack pipe of Trump hatred the analogy
is perfect they need that dopamine dump
because none of it is logical as you've
said for the last 11 months they haven't
been able to say one positive thing
about this president's work whether it's
the stock market the jobs the securing
the border the defeating Isis none of it
matters to them it's all obsessive
psychologically obsessive hatred of a
man who they don't understand and all
the people who voted for him they don't
understand what happened on November the
8th and they still don't get it today
and that's why the hatred continues to
build but they just make themselves
irrelevant Sean and that's great for Fox
and that's great for all Patriots
governor I gotta imagine it's a little
more personal for you when the media is
sitting there attacking your own
daughter and questioning whether or not
she told the truth about making a pie
and they want proof that she made a pie
I mean that's how idiotic and
superfluous some in the media have now
become well first of all I can tell you
she made the pie because she made it for
us at Christmas so that that I can
confirm glad I wasn't there yeah you
don't want this pie but I got to
disagree with both you and dr. Gorka
here's the reason you've said that the
meteor-like drug addicts and I think
that's being very unkind to the drug
addicts because I've known a lot of drug
addicts Sean and a lot of them actually
go into rehab and they get better the
press never gets better they keep
getting worse
they become more obsessed with the
destruction of Donald Trump then they
are with the building up of America
this is a president who's had a
remarkable year oh yeah he says some
things in tweets that drives everybody
off the the ranch but the truth is our
economy's better our security is better
we're trusted by nations that hated us
before and didn't trust us the Middle
East is rapidly changing in a positive
way he's had the guts to stand up for
the Iranian people against their
autocratic totalitarian brutal
terroristic government and they can't
see any of that drug addicts sometimes
have good days I just don't know that
the media is capable of having a good
you're just not able how did they ignore
all of this truth about law-breaking and
corruption how do they not tell any good
story for the most part dr. Gork a very
very little how is it possible that they
won't that they're so myopic that
there's there's nobody in charge saying
guys were a little bit biased here and
it's really obvious this is now a crisis
of confidence in what we do I got AB
imagine there's somebody that wants to
be a professional I think the answer is
very simple Shawn I think yeah you
alluded to it in your monologue because
it's no longer about the truth for these
individuals it's no longer about really
performing a public service journalism
used to be about informing the American
people so they they can make the right
judgments especially when it comes to an
election the media has become like the
Obama White House narrative is
everything remember that dedication to
Hillary's master's thesis she said the
fight is everything it's not about the
truth it's not about America and if you
love America like this president does
like his family does then you are the
problem
remember leadership has been reasserted
whether it's with little Kim in North
Korea whether it's in NATO whether it's
in the Middle East whether it's in
Jerusalem American leadership has been
by Donald J Trump and they can't stand
it because for them we are the problem
America is the problem what should take
Governor on what's going happened
earlier today with Bannon and the
president well it's disappointing and in
part because just a few days ago Steve
Bannon was considered by the press to be
the unhinged he's crazy he's a wild man
suddenly this guy Michael Wolff quotes
him in a book saying terrible things
about President Trump and now he's a
hero but I mean the only gig he's got in
his future is perhaps being a occasional
commentator at MSNBC joining the other
thumb suckers over there who just can't
get enough of themselves but but Shawn
bottom line is this there are two things
you give to someone when you're hired in
a political context you give them
loyalty and you give them
confidentiality those are the two
virtues that are more important than
anything else you can bring and if you
see how many people have maybe been of
the administration they've come out
they've had integrity whether it's Sean
Spicer
Reince Priebus sebastian Gorka there
have been a number of people who came
out and they didn't go out and trash the
president are the other people they
worked with at the White House
Steve Bannon said all along that the
entire Russia investigation was a farce
those are his words a complete farce now
there was no collusion dr. korkor story
changed wasn't donald trump's wasn't
donald trump's doctor last word look
let's let steve talk for himself he's a
big boy
but I know that Mike Wolfe is a hack his
last book 13 people complained about
misquoting and being having that quote
so you suspect he was misquoted look
there was a Twitter feed tonight quoting
me saying something that I wanted to
work for Trump I've never said that I
was told to meet with this man as part
of his book project
I knew his reputation and I refused to
meet with Wolfe The Guardian is the
lowest of the low radical left-wing
newspaper all I know is there is no
Russia collusion because the president
told me so Jared daun jr. are patriots I
care less what the guy said it I wasn't
there and he doesn't sound like look if
Stevie wanted to attack somebody he
wouldn't do it in somebody else's book
he'd do it himself that's the kind of
guy he is
all right guys Thank You ppreciate